>> Tucker: ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG
FREQUENTLY USES RELIGIOUS
RHETORIC.
HE SAYS AMERICAN POLITICS CAN BE
INVITED INTO THE PEOPLE AND
DISSENTERS AND YOU CAN GUESS
WHICH SIDE REPUBLICANS ARE ON.
NOW MAYOR PETE IS GETTING INTO
BIBLICAL SCHOLARSHIP AS WELL.
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW HE
EXPLAINED HOW ACTUALLY THE BIBLE
SAYS THAT UNBORN CHILDREN ARE
NOT ALIVE AND SO ABORTION IS
OKAY.
>> YOU GO THROUGH THE
NEW TESTAMENT, SURE, AND EVERY
OTHER WORD THAT COMES OUT OF THE
MOUTH OF CHRIST IS ABOUT THINGS
LIKE OPEN THOSE IN NEED AND YOU
GOT A REPUBLICAN PARTY DEDICATED
TO ITS OPPOSITE.
THERE WILL BE A RECKONING OVER
IT.
RIGHT NOW THEY HOLD EVERYBODY IN
LINE WITH THIS ONE KIND OF PEACE
OF DOCTRINE ABOUT ABORTION,
RIGHT?
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A TOUGH ISSUE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THEN AGAIN, AS A LOT OF PARTS OF
THE BIBLE TO TALK ABOUT LIFE
BEGINS WITH BREATH AND SO EVEN
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
INTERPRET DIFFERENTLY.
>> Tucker: AT RYAN GLASSMAN IS
SENIOR PASTOR A COMMUNITY CHURCH
OF GOD IN CLEO MICHIGAN, HE IS
ALSO THE BROTHER-IN-LAW OF
MAYOR BUTTIGIEG AND CALLED ON
HIS BROTHER TO REPENT AFTER HIS
LATEST REMARKS.
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU ARE, BY YOUR OWN
DESCRIPTION, NONPOLITICAL, AND
ARE NOT SEEKING TO ATTACK YOUR
BROTHER-IN-LAW, BUT I FELT IT
WOULD BE WORTH GETTING A REVIEW
OF THE THEOLOGY INVOLVED IN THIS
EXPLANATION OF ABORTION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY, THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A PLEA TO PETE
BUTTIGIEG, MY BROTHER-IN-LAW,
THAT WE HE WOULD RECONSIDER HIS
POSITION AND THE WAY HE HAS
MISREPRESENTED SCRIPTURE TO PUSH
THIS PRO-ABORTION PLATFORM THAT
HE'S PUSHING.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PLEA WITH
HIM THAT HE WOULD RECONSIDER AND
ACTUALLY OPEN HIS BIBLE.
I ACTUALLY ASK ALL PEOPLE TO
OPEN UP THEIR BIBLES AS THEY ARE
WATCHING THIS IN TURN TO PSALM
1:30 NINE, SPECIFICALLY VERSES
13 THROUGH 16 AND HOW CAN YOU
READ THOSE PASSAGES THAT TALKS
ABOUT WE ARE FEARFULLY AND
WONDERFULLY MADE IN THE IMAGE OF
GOD, INTRINSICALLY WE ARE WOVEN
TOGETHER IN THE WOMAN'S WOMB.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN READ
THAT AND COME OUT OF THAT WITH
ANY OTHER UNDERSTANDING THAT
LIFE BEGINS AT CONCEPTION AND
WHAT'S EVEN MORE ALARMING IS
THAT THOSE QUESTIONS WILL
WITHSTAND LIKE MAYOR PETE WOULD
AND SAY THAT GOD CONDONES --
THAT GOD SAYS THAT ABORTION IS
OKAY ACCORDING TO SCRIPTURE.
THAT'S JUST ABSURD AND
OUTLANDISH TO ME.
>> Tucker: SO HIS CONTENTION,
AS I AM INTERPRETING IT, IS THAT
THE NEW TESTAMENT SAYS THAT
ABORTION IS FINE UNTIL THE CHILD
DRAWS BREATH IN OTHER WORDS,
REALLY THROUGH THE END OF THE
THIRD TRIMESTER.
DO YOU -- I JUST WANT TO BE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR ON THIS, IS
THERE ANY, IN YOUR VIEW,
CHRISTIAN INTERPRETATION OF THE
BIBLE THAT LEADS TO THAT
CONCLUSION?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE ALL
PEOPLE TO LOOK AT SCRIPTURE --
AGAIN, BACK TO PSALM 1:30 NINE,
THAT WE ARE CREATED AND LIFE
BEGINS AT CONCEPTION.
WE NEED TO GET AWAY -- THIS
ISN'T A POLITICAL THING TO ME,
THIS IS A SPIRITUAL THING TO ME
AND THIS ISN'T THE DIAL OF --
THIS IS A GOD ISSUE.
THIS IS A SPIRITUAL -- NOT A
POLITICAL ISSUE AND TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU, THIS ISN'T EVEN MY
OPINION OR PETE'S OPINION.
THIS IS WHAT DOES GOD SAY, WHAT
DOES THE WORD OF GOD TRULY SAY
IN THE BIBLE IS JUST BEING
MISREPRESENTED AND MISUSED TO
PUSH A PRO-ABORTION AGENDA AND
THAT IS ALARMING, IT'S
DISGUSTING, IT'S FRIGHTENING AND
IT NEEDS TO STOP.
>> Tucker: IT IS ALL OF THOSE
THINGS, I AGREE WITH YOU
COMPLETELY.
HAVING SAID THIS TO YOUR
BROTHER-IN-LAW?
>> I HAVE NOT SPOKEN THIS
DIRECTLY -- I HOPE HE SEES THIS.
I HOPE ALL PEOPLE WATCH THIS AND
HE WILL RECONSIDER, HE WILL
CHANGE HIS POSITION, HE WILL
ACTUALLY OPEN UP THE BIBLE AND
READ THROUGH SCRIPTURE, WHAT
SCRIPTURE ACTUALLY SAYS.
WE NEED TO CREATE A CULTURE THAT
SPEAKS OF HUMAN LIFE AND
HUMAN BEINGS WHO HAVE VALUE.
WE ARE COMMANDED BY CHRIST
HIMSELF TO UPHOLD THE DIGNITY
AND RESPECT OF ALL HUMAN LIFE.
WE NEED TO STAND FOR ALL THE
BORN AND ALL THE UNBORN.
>> Tucker: SO, YOU JUST SAID
YOU WOULD ASK YOUR
BROTHER-IN-LAW TO OPEN UP
SCRIPTURE AND READ THIS.
HIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, AS
I'VE BEEN WATCHING IT, IS BASED
ON THE IDEA THAT HE IS DEEPLY
VERSED IN SCRIPTURE, THAT HE IS
A DEEPLY CHRISTIAN MAN, HE IS
RUNNING AN EXPLICITLY, HE SAYS,
CHRISTIAN CAMPAIGN.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW ANYONE --
WHAT HAPPENS, WE SEE IN SECOND
PETER, CHAPTER FOUR, THAT IS A
TIME, MORE PEOPLE WILL TURN AWAY
FROM DOCTRINE AND ACCUMULATE
TEACHING THAT EACH THEIR EARS.
BASICALLY WHAT THAT PERSUADES
HIS PEOPLE -- WE ARE LIVING IN A
TIME NOW AS WE SEE WITH
MAYOR PETE, THAT PEOPLE ARE
DRIFTING AWAY FROM SOUND
DOCTRINE TO MAKE THE SCRIPTURE
SAY WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO TO
MANIPULATE AND DISTORT
CHRISTIANITY AND WHAT THE WORD
OF GOD SAYS TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DESIRES AND OWN PLEASURE.
REALLY IT BOILS DOWN TO THIS, IS
WHAT I BELIEVE, PEOPLE EITHER
SEEK POWER WHEN THEY ARE GOING
TO STAND UP FOR THE POWERLESS
AND PEOPLE -- THE BABY IN THE
WOMB -- IN THE MOTHER'S WOMB IS
POWERLESS.
IT'S THE MOST VULNERABLE PERSON,
HUMAN LIFE, AND SO PEOPLE HAVE
TO MAKE A DECISION.
PETE HAS TO MAKE A DECISION, ARE
YOU GOING TO STAND UP FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE ARE YOU GOING TO
SEEK THE POWER AND DISTORT
SCRIPTURE TO MEET YOUR OWN
POLITICAL AGENDA THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOT JUST WITH
PETE, WITH THE WHOLE DEMOCRATIC,
RIGHT ON THE LINE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
I THINK IT'S NICELY PUT.
LET ME JUST AND ON THIS,
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS MARRIED TO
YOUR BROTHER.
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO HIM ABOUT
THIS?
>> I AM VERY OPEN ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
AND I HOPE ALL OF THEM SEE THIS.
I AM VERY UNASHAMED OF THE GOOD
NEWS OF.
I'M A PASTOR, I SHARE THE
GOSPEL.
POLITICS IS SECONDARY TO ME, I'M
ABOUT SHARING THE GOOD NEWS OF
CHRIST AND I HOPE PEOPLE
WATCHING THIS -- I REALLY -- I
CHALLENGE AMERICANS AS THESE
DEMOCRATIC DEBATES COME UP HERE
IN A COUPLE OF DAYS AND I'M
ASSUMING THIS TOPIC IS GOING TO
BE BROUGHT UP, THE PEOPLE WOULD
STOP AND ACTUALLY THINK AND
ACTUALLY THINK, WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
WE ARE WITH HUMAN LIFE HERE.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT JUST A
LITTLE BLOB OF CELLS, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HUMAN LIFE, AND
ARE WE GOING TO STAND UP FOR THE
DIGNITY AND RESPECT -- WHEN
PEOPLE STOP AND REALLY THINK
WHAT DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE, NOT
WHAT YOUR PARTY BELIEVES.
IT WOULD BE WONDERFUL TO SEE A
DEMOCRAT -- I'M NOT GOING TO
GOING ON THE TRAIL LEVELED THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO VOTE ON,
I THINK LIFE IN THE WOMB IS
VALUABLE AND HAS INTRINSIC VALUE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOMEONE
STAND UP AND DO THAT.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS SAY SHE